For WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》节目，我是主持人艾拉·格拉斯。
I know how it is to beat somebody. I know how it is to pull the trigger, like drive by [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. I know what it is to pull the trigger. I know what it is to stand in the middle of the street, like a stop sign, throwing out gang signs and expecting a bullet to come to you or somebody to just whack you in the head or something.
我知道打人是什么感觉。我知道扣动扳机是什么感觉，就像驾车枪击一样。我知道扣动扳机是什么滋味。我知道站在街道中央，像个停车标志一样，比划着帮派手势，等待着子弹射向自己，或者等着有人往你头上猛敲一顿是什么感觉。
From the time he was 13 until the time he was 17, Arnie's life was organized around one thing, the Latin Kings, a huge street gang here in Chicago. Then when he was 17, some kids dragged him to youth group and church services until one day, he felt the presence of the lord and he believed. And Arnie quit his gang. He still organized his life around one thing, but now the one thing was God.
从13岁到17岁，阿尼的生活都围绕着一件事：拉丁国王帮，这是芝加哥当地的一个大型街头帮派。17岁那年，一些孩子把他拉到了青年团和教会礼拜，直到有一天，他感受到了上帝的存在并产生了信仰。于是，阿尼退出了帮派。他的生活依然围绕着一件事，但现在这件事变成了上帝。
But when you quit a street gang, one of the problems that you face is that your former enemies do not know that you've quit. They see you on the street and they come after you. And you don't have your old gang to protect you anymore. There's no way to let everybody know. You can't just publish a notice in the federal register in the classified ads of your local paper. And so guys kept coming up to Arnie on the street trying to fight him or shoot him.
但是，当你退出一个街头帮派时，你要面对的问题之一就是，你以前的敌人并不知道你已经退出了。他们在街上见到你，就会追杀你。而你已经没有以前的帮派来保护你了。没法让每个人都知道。你总不能在联邦公报或当地报纸的分类广告里登个声明吧。所以，人们还是会不断在街上找阿尼，想要打他或开枪射他。
Once, for example, some gang kids came up and Arnie happened to be walking with a guy who was a friend of theirs.
比如有一次，几个帮派的孩子冲过来，而阿尼碰巧正和一个他们的朋友走在一起。
So he jumped in front of me before they were going to shoot me and he goes, no, he's a Christian now. He's a man of God. He's not a King anymore. That's the [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]. And the guy was like, no way, I know him. He ain't no Christian. He was like move and then he was going to hit me, right? I was ready to start hitting people and just run. You know just elbow him here, punch him here, and make so I can get out. It's like my mind was ready, boom, take control. Just start fighting. But I just like, wait a minute. No, I'm not going to do that. God has changed me. I'm a new creation like it says in the bible. Therefore, anybody who's in Christ a new creation, the old has gone, the new has come. And I am the new that has come.
他跳到我面前，在他们要开枪之前说：“不，他现在是基督徒了。他是上帝的人。他不再是国王帮的人了。那是……”那个家伙说：“不可能，我认识他。他才不是什么基督徒。”他喊着让他走开，然后就想打我，对吧？我当时已经准备好要揍人了，然后就跑。你知道，肘击这里，拳击这里，好让自己脱身。我的大脑当时准备好了，“砰”的一声，掌控局面。直接开始打架。但我对自己说，“等一下。不，我不能那样做。上帝改变了我。就像圣经里说的，我是个新造的人。因此，任何在基督里的人，都是新造的人，旧事已过，一切都变成新的了。而我就是那个重获新生的人。”
I just looked around. I was just like, hey. I just said, look, I'm a man of God now. You do what you got to do. You know what I'm saying? But I don't gang bang no more. And soon I hope to see you in our church praise the lord together. So he was like, man. So he got mad, real mad. He just said, forget you, man. And he walked away and all his boys walked back to the car and they didn't do nothing to me.
我只是环顾四周，对他们说：“嘿，听着，我现在是上帝的人了。你们想做什么就做吧。你们懂我的意思吗？但我不再参与帮派斗争了。我希望很快能在我们的教堂见到你们，一起赞美主。”他听了之后很生气，非常生气。他只是说：“去你的吧，伙计。”然后就走开了，他所有的手下也回到了车里，他们没对我做任何事。
Arnie told me a lot of these stories. And they're all like stories from the Bible. The stories where Paul goes out among the non-believers and they want to hurt him and he's filled with the holy spirit, the bible says. And then for some reason, because I guess he's filled with the holy spirit, they do not hurt him. Sometimes Arnie think his life is lot like those stories.
阿尼跟我讲过很多这样的故事。它们就像圣经里的故事一样。保罗在非信徒中传道，他们想要伤害他，但圣经说他心中充满了圣灵。然后出于某种原因，我想是因为他充满了圣灵，他们就没有伤害他。有时阿尼觉得他的生活就像那些故事一样。
The one I like the best is Stephen in the Book of Acts when he got stoned. I love that story because I feel like Stephen is me. Yeah, like I'm Stephen. I'm not, but like we got the same spirits, which we do. How they have him ready to persecute him and he's like, he's not afraid to tell the truth. In other words, he's down for his. He's willing to live and die for what he believes in. Just like when you're willing to live and die for gang bang. Like me, I was a Latin King. You know what I'm saying? You got to live and die for that crown, right? And that's what he was dying for. He was dying for God. You know, our lord. He's there, he's been done. He's standing up firm. He's like, I don't care about anybody. Just like when you're on the street. I don't care. I'm a Latin King. What's up? You know, I don't care. What's up? They beat their chests with their gang sign. You know, what's up? What's up? I'm this and this and that. They're not afraid or ashamed to say who they are.
我最喜欢的是《使徒行传》中司提反被乱石打死的故事。我喜欢那个故事，因为我觉得司提反就是我。没错，就像我就是司提反。我虽然不是，但我们有着同样的灵魂，确实如此。他们想要迫害他时，他并不害怕说出真相。换句话说，他为了自己的信念坚守到底。他愿意为自己的信仰而生，为自己的信仰而死。就像当你愿意为帮派火拼而生、而死一样。像我，我以前是拉丁国王帮的。你懂我意思吗？你必须为那个王冠而活、为它而死，对吧？而他就是为了上帝而死。你知道，我们的主。他在那儿，他已经完成了。他坚定地站着。他就像是说：“我不在乎任何人。就像你在街上一样。我不在乎。我是拉丁国王帮的。怎么着？你知道，我不在乎。怎么着？”他们拍着胸脯，比划着帮派手势。你知道，“怎么着？怎么着？我是谁谁谁。”他们不害怕，也不为自己的身份感到羞耻。
There are people for whom everything in the world comes down to one thing. One idea, one belief, and they organize their whole understanding of the world around that belief. The belief might be God, or free market economics, or animal rights, or the ozone layer. And some people structure their lives around collecting old records, or around sex, or theater, or politics, or Star Trek , or basketball.
这世上有些人，万事万物对他们来说都归结为一件事。一个理念，一个信仰，他们将自己对世界的全部理解都组织在这个信仰周围。这个信仰可能是上帝，可能是自由市场经济，可能是动物权利，也可能是臭氧层。有些人则将生活围绕着收集旧唱片，或者是性、戏剧、政治、星际迷航或篮球而构建。
I've been a one thing person. Maybe you've been a one thing person too. Arnie certainly was. And his new one thing, the lord, filled the same place in his life that the old one thing, the gang, used to.
我曾经也是个“一件事”主义者。也许你也是。阿尼肯定是的。而他现在的新“一件事”——上帝，在他生命中占据了和旧的“一件事”——帮派，曾经占据的一模一样的位置。
You know, sometimes I want to give it all, just like I give it all to my gang. I want to give it all to him. Even double, you know. I want to die for the lord. I don't care if I get crucified. I don't care if they shoot me.
你知道，有时我想付出一切，就像我曾经为帮派付出一切那样。我想把一切都献给他。甚至是双倍的，你知道。我想为上帝而死。我不在乎是否被钉死在十字架上。我不在乎他们是否向我开枪。
You feel the same way about Christianity as you did about the gang?
你对基督教的感受和你对帮派的感受一样吗？
Yeah, exactly. It's like I have the same mentality and the same heart, but now it's for a different reason and a different person.
是的，完全一样。就像我有着同样的心态和同样的内心，但现在是为了不同的理由，为了不同的人。
Well, today on our program, One Thing People. People who organize their lives around just one idea and the price they pay for that.
今天在我们的节目中，我们要聊聊“一件事”主义者。那些将生活完全围绕一个理念组织起来的人，以及他们为此付出的代价。
Act One, when your one thing is your ex-girlfriend.
第一幕，当你的“一件事”是你的前女友时。
Act Two, Inescapable Logic. What happens when you take a utopian vision of nudism, yes, nudism, to its logical end as your one thing. This is the true story of a nude presidential candidate.
第二幕，不可逃避的逻辑。当你把裸体主义——没错，就是裸体主义——的乌托邦愿景作为你唯一的追求，并将其推向逻辑尽头时，会发生什么？这是一个裸体总统候选人的真实故事。
Act Three, more than one thing. How journalist Philip Weiss came to agree with some Clinton conspiracy theorists, but decided not to follow their cause.
第三幕，不止一件事。记者菲利普·韦斯如何开始认同克林顿阴谋论者的一些观点，却决定不去追随他们的事业。
Act Four, Quitting Quitting. Regrets from a former one-thinger. Stay with us.
第四幕，戒掉戒除。一个曾经的“一件事”主义者的悔悟。请继续收听。
Act One, Life Without Leanne.
第一幕，没有莉安的生活。
Well, let's start our show with the kind of one thing behavior most people at some point or another have gone through themselves. Taken, perhaps just a step or two further than most of us have taken it.
好吧，让我们从大多数人在某种程度上都经历过的那种“一件事”行为开始我们今天的节目。只不过，这比我们大多数人走得稍微远了那么一点。
Good evening and welcome to Life Without Leanne. I'm Larry and this is day 683. That's nearly 98 weeks since Leanne and I broke up.
晚上好，欢迎收听《没有莉安的生活》。我是拉里，今天是第683天。距离我和莉安分手已经快98周了。
We're going to start out, as always, with our Leanne watcher of the week. My kudos go out to Mike of Evanston, Illinois, who called in with this eloquent report on a brief encounter he had with Leanne on April 28.
我们要像往常一样，先请出我们本周的“莉安观察员”。我要向伊利诺伊州埃文斯顿的迈克致敬，他打来电话，讲述了4月28日他与莉安的一次短暂邂逅，报告非常精彩。
Hey, Larry. I love the show. Listen, I ran into Leanne last week. She lost some weight, but she's still beautiful. She said she's been exercising, taking classes, doing this, doing that. But it appeared to me that she was struggling to fill some void. Your name didn't come up, but it wasn't so much what she said as what she didn't say.
嘿，拉里。我喜欢这个节目。听着，我上周遇到了莉安。她瘦了一些，但依然很漂亮。她说她一直在锻炼，参加各种课程，做这做那。但在我看来，她是在努力填补某种空虚。她没提到你的名字，但重点不在于她说了什么，而在于她没说什么。
Thanks, Mike. I think we all know what she was trying to say.
谢谢你，迈克。我想我们都知道她想表达什么。
I wish it all could be such good news. But unfortunately, Operation Terrible Mistake has not been the success that we anticipated and I'm afraid we may have to rethink our strategy. As you may recall from our April 20 program, the objectives of Operation Terrible Mistake were to one, apply societal pressure. Two, foster emotional uncertainty. Three, precipitate reevaluation. And ideally, four, achieve reconciliation.
我希望一切都能有这么好的消息。但不幸的是，“恐怖错误行动”并没有像我们预期的那样成功，恐怕我们得重新考虑策略了。正如你们可能还记得我们在4月20日节目中提到的，“恐怖错误行动”的目标是：第一，施加社会压力；第二，制造情绪上的不确定性；第三，促使她重新评估；理想情况下，第四，实现复合。
When I brought up this plan, I suggested the following conversation starter when you would run into Leanne on the street or something. I suggested that you say something like, "Leanne, I was so sorry to hear about you and Larry. You make such a wonderful couple, so I don't mind telling you I think you are making a terrible mistake. This is my own personal opinion on the matter."
当我提出这个计划时，我建议在街上或其他地方偶遇莉安时使用以下对话开头。我建议你这样说：“莉安，听说你和拉里的事我很遗憾。你们曾是一对多么棒的伴侣，所以我不介意告诉你，我认为你犯了一个严重的错误。这是我个人的看法。”
Now unfortunately, a number of well meaning individuals took this suggestion rather more literally than I intended and repeated it verbatim to Leanne. And some of it sounds like you were practicing it and it created an effect other than the one I desired. I've now received word through an intermediary that Leanne request that I quote, "Call off the zombies," unquote. We will honor her wishes as always. But I must emphasize, I cannot be held responsible for the behavior of individuals acting on their own initiative.
不幸的是，一些善意的人把这个建议执行得比我预想的更字面化，并一字不差地复述给了莉安。而且有些人听起来像是在演习，这造成了我所期望之外的效果。我现在通过中间人收到消息，莉安要求我，引用她的话，“叫停这些僵尸”。我们将一如既往地尊重她的意愿。但我必须强调，对于那些自作主张的个人行为，我不承担任何责任。
When Leanne was Little, number 36 in the series.
《莉安小时候》，系列第36集。
At our regular Monday lunch, Leanne's mother told me a cute story. She says that when Leanne was seven, she fell while roller skating and badly skinned her knee. There was no permanent scarring fortunately. In an effort to console her, Leanne's mother recalls telling Leanne, if you don't stop crying, your boo-boo is going to think you don't like him. And that's why, to this day, Leanne endearingly refers to minor cuts and scrapes as Mr. Boo.
在我们固定的周一午餐会上，莉安的母亲给我讲了一个可爱的故事。她说莉安七岁时，滑旱冰摔倒，膝盖擦伤得很严重。幸运的是没有留下永久疤痕。为了安慰她，莉安的妈妈记得自己告诉莉安：“如果你再不停止哭泣，你的伤口会觉得你不喜欢它。”这就是为什么直到今天，莉安还会亲昵地把小伤口和小擦伤称为“布先生”。
I've got the minutes to the most recent Leanne Anonymous Meeting, which I'll read to you now. It was our first meeting at Gatsby's. The bartender, Mark, graciously accommodated us by closing off the back room and supplying extra folding chairs. All in attendance praised the wisdom of moving these meetings from my apartment, which some of them had complained was not in neutral territory and it was getting kind of cramped in any case.
我拿到了最近一次“莉安匿名互助会”的会议记录，现在读给你们听。这是我们在盖茨比酒吧举行的第一次会议。酒保马克非常慷慨，通过关掉后厅并提供额外的折叠椅来安置我们。所有参加者都称赞将会议从我的公寓搬出来的明智之举，之前有人抱怨那里不是中立地带，而且无论如何，那地方也确实太拥挤了。
On a related matter, Mark told me privately after the meeting that he appreciates our patronage, but he asks that in the future we try not to monopolize the jukebox. Or at least try to play a variety of songs. He's threatening to remove all the Hank Williams selections if he doesn't see some improvement. So let's all try to work some Patsy Cline in there or something, OK?
相关的事，马克在会后私下告诉我，他很感激我们的光顾，但要求我们在未来尽量不要霸占点唱机。或者至少尝试播放多种多样的歌曲。他威胁说，如果看不到改进，就要撤掉所有的汉克·威廉姆斯精选。所以，大家都试着在里面加入一些帕齐·克莱恩的歌，好吗？
Meeting started out. We ordered a first round and at Tom's suggestion, we dispensed with the reading of the minutes. We proceeded immediately to old business. The continuing debate on Leanne's eyes and whether they are turbulent sea green or sand fleck moon blue. They are, by the way, a sand fleck moon blue.
会议开始了。我们点了第一轮酒，在汤姆的建议下，我们省去了阅读会议记录的环节。直接进入旧议题。关于莉安眼睛颜色的持续争论：到底是波涛汹涌的海绿色，还是沙点月光蓝。顺便说一下，它们的颜色是沙点月光蓝。
But when it appeared there could be no middle ground on the issue, Dick stood up and announced, hey, you know, like Elton John says, who cares if they're blue or they're green. Those are the sweetest eyes I've ever seen.
但当这个问题似乎无法达成共识时，迪克站起来宣布：“嘿，你们知道的，就像埃尔顿·约翰唱的那样，‘谁在乎它们是蓝是绿，那是我见过最甜美的双眼’。”
The motion to adopt Dick's language carried unanimously and we collected more change for the jukebox.
采纳迪克措辞的动议获得一致通过，我们又为点唱机凑了一些零钱。
We ordered another round and conversation turned naturally to the rest of Leanne. Her quirky, perky nose, her funny, sunny smile, the perfect curve or her neck. Her soft shoulders and so on. Until petty jealousies precluded further discussion.
我们又点了下一轮酒，谈话自然地转向了莉安的其他部分。她古灵精怪、充满活力的鼻子，她滑稽、阳光的笑容，她颈部完美的曲线。她柔软的肩膀等等。直到小小的嫉妒心阻止了进一步的讨论。
Soon thereafter, we took a break to order some more refreshments, and then it was time to welcome new members. This stubby and not particularly attractive man who had been spotted with Leanne as recently as mid January stood up and he said, My name's Harry and I love Leanne.
此后不久，我们休息了一下，点了些点心，然后是欢迎新成员的时间。这个身材敦实、长相并不出众的男人，曾于1月中旬被发现与莉安在一起，他站起来说：“我叫哈里，我爱莉安。”
Harry then related his long, sad tale. The details of which we are all too familiar with. He ended with that same old refrain, she met this guy. She says she's deliriously happy. That prompted Gunther, who really doesn't speak very often to speak up.
哈里随后讲述了他漫长而悲伤的故事，其中的细节我们都已经太熟悉了。他以那句老调重弹结束：“她遇到了那个家伙。她说她现在快乐得要命。”这促使平时不怎么说话的冈瑟插了一句嘴。
She's deliriously happy, eh?, he said, staring into his beer. That guy is doomed. Those who could still laugh about it, did.
“快乐得要命，哈？”他盯着杯中的啤酒说道。“那家伙死定了。”那些还能笑得出来的人，都笑了。
Really, Harry said. So you think then, there's a chance I could win her back? This question prompted extensive debate, leading to the inevitable threats of violence. It only ceased when Quentin moved that we change the name of the group from Lovers of Leanne to Victims of Leanne. That motion was soundly defeated of course, and we voted to adjourn.
“真的吗？”哈里说，“所以你们认为，我还有机会赢回她吗？”这个问题引发了广泛的争论，导致了不可避免的暴力威胁。只有当昆汀提议我们将小组名称从“莉安的爱人们”改为“莉安的受害者们”时，争论才停止。当然，该动议被彻底否决，我们投票解散。
Elmo closed the meeting by singing "Oh, Leanne." Including this new verse that had recently come to him in a dream. I have a recording.
埃尔莫以演唱《哦，莉安》结束了会议。其中包括他最近在梦中得到的这一段新歌词。我有录音。
[SINGING] Oh, Leanne. I love you. Love you. Still. I love you. I love you. I love you. Still. I always will.
[歌唱] 哦，莉安。我爱你。爱你。依然。我爱你。我爱你。我爱你。依然。我永远都会。
It's about Leanne.
这首歌是关于莉安的。
OK, a Leanne announcement. My special friend, Jane, who has been so supportive during this difficult time has suggested that there might be a need for a group addressing the concerns of the lovers of the lovers of Leanne. Anybody who knows somebody who might be interested in such a group should have them write LeanneANON in care of this station.
好了，一个关于莉安的公告。我的好朋友简，在这段困难时期给予了我极大的支持，她建议可能需要成立一个专门关注“莉安爱人们的爱人们”的群体。任何认识可能对此类群体感兴趣的人，请让他们写信给本电台，收件人为“莉安匿名互助会”。
We all know what that music means. It's time for this week's Leanne challenge. Leanne is what she eats, but how well do you know what she eats? Everybody knows Leanne likes horseradish on her hamburgers. But what kind of horseradish?
我们都知道那段音乐意味着什么。现在是本周的“莉安挑战”时间。莉安吃什么就是什么，但你对她的饮食习惯了解多少？每个人都知道莉安喜欢在汉堡里加辣根。但到底是什么样的辣根？
OK, here's a hint. She received a case of it last Christmas. The answer to last week's challenge was, you guessed it, from left to right. I know a lot of people thought there was a trick to that question, but there wasn't.
好了，给个提示。她去年圣诞节收到了一整箱。上周挑战的答案是，你猜对了，从左到右。我知道很多人觉得那个问题有陷阱，但其实并没有。
Time for the mail. The mail ran heavy this week with entries to the Candid Leanne Photo Contest. I think I need to remind everybody that the rules clearly state that Leanne must be the only person shown in the photograph. In case any of you want to resubmit, I'm going to extend the deadline for two weeks until May 23. Please remember entries can't be returned.
邮件时间到了。本周收到的《莉安素颜照片大赛》参赛作品非常多。我想我需要提醒大家，规则明确规定照片中必须只能出现莉安一人。如果你们中有人想重新提交，我将把截止日期延长两周，至5月23日。请记住，参赛作品恕不退还。
OK, first letter. One of our far-flung correspondents, Myles, writes from Lexington, Kentucky.
好了，第一封信。我们远方的通讯员之一，迈尔斯，从肯塔基州的列克星敦寄来的。
I'm going to be in town in the near future and I was hoping to finally meet this Leanne I've heard so much about. Do you have her phone number and address where I can write her directly?
我很快就要去城里了，我希望能最终见到这位我听过这么多故事的莉安。你有她的电话号码和地址吗？我可以写信直接寄给她。
Well, Myles, there's really no need for that. Why don't you just send your correspondence to Leanne in care of me and I'll make sure she gets it.
嗯，迈尔斯，真的没必要那样做。你为什么不把信寄给莉安，收件人写我这里，我会确保她收到的。
And we also have a letter here from Reggie of Buffalo Grove, Illinois, who writes in. I think this is very interesting. We've gotten a number of letters like this.
我们这里还有一封信，来自伊利诺伊州布法罗格罗夫的雷吉，他写道：我认为这非常有趣。我们已经收到很多这样的信件了。
He writes, Larry, isn't it time you got on with your life? It's been nearly two years since Leanne broke up with you.
他写道：“拉里，是不是该开始你自己的生活了？莉安和你分手已经快两年了。”
Actually, we're a couple weeks short of that, but anyway.
实际上，离那个时间还有几周，但不管怎样。
He says, it's been actually two years since Leanne broke up with you and I hate to tell you, pal, but it's over. O-V-E-R. But listen, he says, there are a lot of other chicks in the sea, my friend. And they're yours for the picking. Go for it.
他说：“实际上，莉安和你分手已经两年了，我很不想这么说，哥们儿，但一切都结束了。结—束—了。但是听着，”他说，“海里还有很多别的姑娘，我的朋友。她们等着你去挑选。去吧。”
Well, Reggie. I don't know quite how to answer that. It's difficult to determine exactly what it is you're driving at. I mean, I'm afraid I don't share your bitter perspective and I don't really get all of your playground aphorisms. But please understand when I suggest this. You know nothing about love. But thanks for the letter, Regg. Your Larry Loves Leanne t-shirt is in the mail. That's it for Life Without Leanne this week. And let's hope it's the last week. I'm Larry and I love Leanne.
好吧，雷吉。我真不知道该怎么回答。很难确定你到底想表达什么。我的意思是，恐怕我无法分享你那种刻薄的观点，我也实在搞不懂你的那些大道理。但请在提出这些建议时理解这一点：你对爱一无所知。不过还是谢谢你的来信，雷吉。你的“拉里爱莉安”T恤已经在邮寄的路上了。本周的《没有莉安的生活》到此结束。希望这会是最后一周。我是拉里，我爱莉安。
Larry Doyle writes for The Simpsons and wishes it known that he now loves Becky.
拉里·多伊尔为《辛普森一家》撰稿，并希望大家知道他现在爱的是贝基。
Act Two, Inescapable Logic. When you're seized by one idea, by one thing, it's not like you choose it. It's like it chooses you. And often the one thing has a logic to it that seems inescapable. These are perfectly logical consistent systems once you get inside them. Macrobiotics, Mormonism, the JFK assassination theories.
第二幕，不可逃避的逻辑。当你被一个理念、被一件事所占据时，这不像是一种选择。感觉像是它选择了你。通常，“一件事”有一种看似不可逃避的逻辑。一旦你进入其中，这些系统就是逻辑严密且自洽的。长寿饮食法、摩门教、肯尼迪遇刺阴谋论皆是如此。
This is a story of someone who found the logic of his one thing irresistible and he followed that logic to its logical end. And it's the story of what happened to him as a result. This is a true story set in 1976. Chicago playwright, Beau O'Reilly, tells this story.
这是一个关于某人发现了他心中那一件事的逻辑不可抗拒，并追随该逻辑直至终点的故事。这是一个关于他最终遭遇的故事。这是一个发生在1976年的真实故事。芝加哥剧作家博·奥赖利讲述了这个故事。
Before we begin, a quick parental advisory. There is nudity in this story. No sex, nothing very explicit, but there is nudity.
在开始之前，一个简短的家长建议。这个故事里有裸体内容。没有性行为，没有什么非常露骨的东西，但有裸体。
Eddie Hickock Collins taught high school English in Baldwin, Long Island. Remedial readers whose attention spans kept them far away from Herman Melville or Nathaniel Hawthorne. Holden Caulfield in Catcher in The Rye , those seemed just right to Eddie, despite the fact that Catcher in The Rye was on the banned bookshelf of the school library.
埃迪·希科克·柯林斯在长岛鲍德温教高中英语。那些阅读困难的学生注意力范围远不及赫尔曼·梅尔维尔或纳撒尼尔·霍桑。在《麦田里的守望者》中，霍尔顿·考菲尔德对埃迪来说似乎恰到好处，尽管事实上《麦田里的守望者》当时在学校图书馆的禁书架上。
The library didn't like the use of the F word on page 201 of Catcher in The Rye . But page 201 was Eddie Collins' favorite page. And he figured his remedial readers would love it too. His young hooligans who all wanted and needed to get naked and needed page 201 thought Eddie.
图书馆不喜欢《麦田里的守望者》第201页上使用F开头的词。但第201页是埃迪·柯林斯最喜欢的一页。他觉得他的差生们也会喜欢它的。他那些渴望也需要变得赤裸、并且需要第201页的少年捣蛋鬼们，埃迪心想。
The school soon gave notice though. Under no circumstances was he to teach that dirty Catcher in The Rye. The F word, beloved page 201. They were deemed questionable and inappropriate.
但学校很快就发出了通知。无论如何，他都不准教那本肮脏的《麦田里的守望者》。那个F开头的词，心爱的第201页。它们被认为是有问题的和不恰当的。
Eddie began reading the book aloud to his remedial class that day. And the remedial readers all took notice. They nodded and they grunted at all the good parts. And running their long, adolescent fingers over and over through their greasy pompadours as good, old Holden Caulfield rolled along. And cheering and chanting out the F word when Eddie tore into page 201.
埃迪那天开始向他的差生班朗读这本书。那些学生全都注意听了。他们对所有精彩的部分点头赞许、咕哝着回应。当老霍尔顿·考菲尔德的故事推进时，他们用长长的、青春期的手指一遍又一遍地梳理着自己油腻的蓬巴杜发型。而当埃迪撕开第201页读到那个词时，他们欢呼雀跃，齐声高喊。
Edward Hickock Collins was fired from teaching high school English in Baldwin, Long Island. And he spent the rest of that year pacing in front of the fireplace at his mother's house.
爱德华·希科克·柯林斯被长岛鲍德温的高中解聘了。那一年的余下时间，他都在他母亲家的壁炉前踱步。
It was a cold winter, but Eddie was already heated up from his recent battle with censorship, so Eddie pulled off more and more of his clothes. His shirt, his shoes, his pants. And he flung them in all directions. Eddie built up the fire and he sweated aloud. If he couldn't teach the F word, how could he live free? That he demanded of himself. The F word, the sex act. That had to be naked and lovely. That felt right and right felt natural. And why hide that, Eddie thought. And that's when he first thought it. He would never dress again.
那是一个寒冷的冬天，但埃迪因最近那场反审查制度的战斗而变得亢奋，于是埃迪脱掉了越来越多的衣服。他的衬衫、鞋子、裤子。他把它们向各个方向扔去。埃迪生起了火，大声喘着气。如果他不能教授那个词，他还怎么能活得自由？他对自己发出质问。那个词，性行为。那必须是赤裸而可爱的。那感觉是对的，而正确的感觉是自然的。埃迪心想，为什么要隐藏这些呢？就在那时，他有了第一个想法。他再也不会穿衣服了。
You know how an idea catches and grabs a hold of you? Maybe you've had that. An idea that speaks to your most private imaginings and your deepest hurt feelings, your most secret strange joys. And that idea says, here I am. Change everything because I'm here. I'm perfect. I'm enlightened by sexuality. I'm the new laughing cure for cancer. I am my body and shape and in perfect yoga pose. And these ideas fuel so crucial that the access of your world turns to embrace them.
你知道一个想法是如何捕捉并抓住你的吗？也许你也有过这样的经历。一个触动你最私密的幻想、最深沉受伤的情感、最隐秘奇异的快乐的想法。那个想法说：“我就在这里。改变一切吧，因为我在这里。我是完美的。我被性启蒙。我是癌症的新型幽默疗法。我是我的身体，我的形态，我的完美瑜伽姿势。”这些想法如此至关重要，以至于你世界的轴心都随之转动以拥抱它们。
Eddie's idea felt like that. And Eddie's idea was naked and it was obvious. It was without guilt or second thought. Nudity. Nudity now.
埃迪的想法就是这种感觉。而埃迪的想法是赤裸的，显而易见的。它没有负罪感，也没有第二种想法。裸体。现在就裸体。
Eddie ran naked all the way to the high school. It was his first nude run. His body was flapping like a ship that has come free of its moorings and is now spinning and reckless in the surf.
埃迪赤身裸体一路跑向高中。这是他第一次裸奔。他的身体像一艘脱离了系泊的船，在浪潮中疯狂地旋转，毫无拘束。
And at the high school, all his former students, the remedial readers, they were playing manic playground basketball. And Eddie happily ran out on the court. He wanted to dunk a few in the glorious springtime. Dunk a few and then tell the smart guys of his new vision of freedom.
在高中，他以前所有的学生，那些差生，正在疯狂地玩着操场篮球。埃迪快乐地冲上球场。他想在辉煌的春日里扣上几个篮。扣上几个篮，然后告诉这些“聪明人”他那关于自由的新愿景。
And Eddie yelled in his joy as he hit the court, but his remedial readers weren't glad to see him. They turned away, laughing, embarrassed by Eddie's nakedness. And they refused to pass him the ball.
埃迪满心欢喜地大喊着跑上球场，但那些差生看到他并不高兴。他们转过身去，嘲笑着，为埃迪的裸体感到尴尬。他们拒绝传球给他。
And when Eddie persisted, he leaped at each one of the boys in turn. One of them grabbed the ball and smacked it into Eddie's face hard. So hard the ball flip stung and bled and Eddie's eyes filled with tears.
当埃迪坚持时，他依次扑向每一个男孩。其中一个抢过球，重重地砸在埃迪脸上。那球砸得非常疼，他流血了，埃迪的眼里噙满了泪水。
Eddie was lost then. The remedial readers surrounded and hounded him. Oh, they flicked popsicle sticks and clouds of dirt at his exposed penis and his poor back side.
埃迪在那一刻迷失了。那些学生包围并驱赶他。哦，他们弹着冰棍棒，将尘土扬向他暴露的生殖器和他可怜的背部。
And Eddie slammed the door of his mother's house. He was crying and he was shaking. And all the remedial readers, they gathered in a pack outside. They were flushed and they talked themselves into a deeper hatred. And one of them grabbed a brick and threw it through Eddie's mother's picture window and shattered it. And then there was such a roar of rage and hurt and it just ripped through Eddie's brain and he grabbed the same brick and he threw it back through the same window. The remaining glass just flying. And then, Eddie jumped through the now open window, falling and gashing his poor hands and his poor feet.
埃迪砰地一声关上母亲家的门。他哭着，颤抖着。而所有那些差生，他们在外面聚集成群。他们满脸通红，鼓动自己产生更深的仇恨。其中一个抓起一块砖头，砸向埃迪母亲的画窗，玻璃碎了。接着，一阵愤怒和伤害的咆哮穿过了埃迪的大脑，他抓起同一块砖头，又把它扔回了同一个窗户。剩下的玻璃随之飞溅。然后，埃迪跳过了现在洞开的窗户，重重摔倒，划伤了他可怜的手脚。
The remedial readers running in all directions. Eddie landing on a lawn of glass. And when he looked up in the sky, written in huge letters of flaming black and red six feet high were the words, "Why? Don't ask why. Live."
差生们四散奔逃。埃迪跌落在满是玻璃的草坪上。当他抬头望向天空时，上面用六英尺高、燃烧着的黑红字母写着：“为什么？别问为什么。活下去。”
And right then, something deep exploded in Eddie. And his face and his heart, his whole being, flushed with joy.
就在那一刻，埃迪内心深处爆发了什么。他的脸庞、他的心脏、他的整个人，都充满了喜悦。
Shock treatments are serious and they're undermining. And in Eddie, they led him to a decade of quiet years. Years in which he memorized D.H. Lawrence's Women in Love from cover to cover. But his body, his naked body, lay in waiting. Impatient for the day when the clothes would come off and his body could go public again.
休克疗法是严肃的，且具有破坏性。对埃迪来说，这导致了他十年宁静的岁月。在那几年里，他将D.H.劳伦斯的《恋爱中的女人》从头到尾背了下来。但他的身体，他赤裸的身体，一直守候着。不耐烦地等待着那一天：衣服脱掉，他的身体可以再次出现在公众视野中。
Eddie Hickock Collins came to Dekalb, Illinois, to work on the railroad. And he grew a huge, red beard that shouted out a fanfare wherever he went.
埃迪·希科克·柯林斯来到伊利诺伊州的迪卡尔布铁路工作。他留起了一部巨大的红胡子，无论走到哪里，那部胡子都在为他进行着狂热的宣传。
The Palace was our vegetarian restaurant theater and coffeehouse. It was work and it was home for we young anti-war hippies. It was a workshop for our ideas on how to change the troubled world that we'd been given by our parents. But it was also a refuge. And a magnet, a magnet for people who were obsessed with one idea. And for the odd.
“宫殿”是我们当时素食餐厅的剧院和咖啡馆。那是我们这些年轻反战嬉皮士的工作地和家。那是我们实践那些关于如何改变父母留给我们的这个麻烦世界的想法的实验室。但它也是一个避难所。一个磁铁，一个吸引那些执着于某个理念的人、吸引怪人的磁铁。
If your father was a mason and now you'd lost your chi and you were doomed to wander the five room universe of The Palace looking for it. If you were hopelessly shy and allergic to the 20th century, and everything that made it tick. If you were a closet arsonist who just needed a place to rest and battle the flames inside you. If you were a bottom pincher who drank too much schnapps and read only 17th century literature, you were welcome at The Palace.
如果你的父亲是个泥瓦匠，而你现在失去了灵魂，注定要在“宫殿”那五间房的宇宙里徘徊寻找；如果你极其害羞，对一切使20世纪运转的东西过敏；如果你是一个内心渴望纵火但只需要一个地方安顿并与内心火焰战斗的人；如果你是一个整天喝太多杜松子酒、只读17世纪文学的摸底控，那么“宫殿”欢迎你。
You could bring your dogs and your books and your bare feet. And as long as you didn't drink Coca-Cola there and at least considered not paying your war taxes, you were welcome. And we would never call the police.
你可以带着你的狗、你的书和你赤裸的双脚来。只要你不喝可口可乐，并且至少考虑不交战争税，你就是受欢迎的。而且我们绝不会报警。
Eddie set up outside The Palace, smiling and silent at first, and he offered his own newsletter, The Beast of Revelation. A passionate, journalistic banner that proclaims the beauty of the human body. The penis is glorious and the vagina is magical. They have to be seen to be believed argued The Beast of Revelations. And after Eddie had figured most of us, the hippie community of The Palace, had a grasp of his basic message, Eddie came in off the sidewalk and he began to talk to us.
埃迪起初在“宫殿”外微笑而沉默，他分发自己的通讯小册子《启示录之兽》。那是一份激情澎湃、充满新闻色彩的横幅，宣扬人体之美。“阴茎是光辉的，阴道是神奇的。”《启示录之兽》辩称，“必须亲眼看见才能相信。”在埃迪觉得我们——“宫殿”的嬉皮士社区——大部分人都理解了他的基本信息后，埃迪从人行道走进来，开始与我们交谈。
He was a public speaker. Could he speak there? Eddie we had a voice and his eyes were wide awake and the title of this first talk was, "Nudity. Nudity Now."
他是一位演说家。他能在那儿发言吗？埃迪有声音，他的眼睛瞪得很大，这第一次演讲的标题是：“裸体。现在就裸体。”
He quoted liberally from the D.H Lawrence's Women in Love. Lawrence is big. Oh, he's big. Nudity and orgasm equals freedom. That's what D.H Lawrence sees. And Lawrence sees me, Eddie. Lawrence agrees with Collins. Nudity, sexuality, they form a square knot of human perfection.
他大量引用了D.H.劳伦斯的《恋爱中的女人》。劳伦斯是伟大的。哦，他是伟大的。裸体加高潮等于自由。这就是D.H.劳伦斯看到的。而劳伦斯看到了我，埃迪。劳伦斯同意柯林斯的观点。裸体、性，它们构成了人类完美的死结。
Until the Catholic church and public education get ahold of you. Oh, they'll twist you and they'll shame you. And that's bad. It's bad. Read Lawrence. He knows. He's big. Nudity. Nudity now.
直到天主教会和公共教育机构抓住了你。哦，他们会扭曲你，他们会羞辱你。那是不好的。这很糟糕。读读劳伦斯吧。他懂。他很伟大。裸体。现在就裸体。
We all laughed not knowing why. And at the end of each performance, we followed Eddie out on the sidewalk. Eddie tossing his clothes in all directions before running off, naked into the night. Dekalb was a small place, but by the next week when Eddie spoke there was a real crowd that followed him outside for his personal unveiling.
我们都笑了，却不知道为什么。在每次表演结束时，我们都会跟着埃迪走到人行道上。埃迪将衣服向各个方向抛去，然后赤身裸体地跑进黑夜。迪卡尔布是个小地方，但到了下周埃迪再次演讲时，有一群人真正跟着他走到外面，看他个人的“揭幕仪式”。
Edward Hickock Collins blossomed with nudity and attention. And by the fourth week, with the crowd urging him on, the clothes came off on stage and Eddie became the nude public speaker. Speaking out, but speaking nude, he shouted.
爱德华·希科克·柯林斯因裸体和关注而绽放。到了第四周，在人群的怂恿下，衣服在舞台上脱掉了，埃迪成了裸体公开演说家。他大喊着，发言，但他是赤裸着发言。
And Eddie now began his talks naked and he hung around naked. He could be found at The Palace at all hours naked. Sometimes we politely asked him to dress for an occasion like when someone's parents came to town and then Eddie would put on this kilt. A kilt he made out of a pair of cut-off jeans slashed free at the legs.
埃迪现在开始赤裸着进行他的谈话，并赤裸着四处游荡。他可以在“宫殿”的任何时候被发现——赤裸着。有时我们会礼貌地要求他在某些场合穿上衣服，比如当某人的父母来访时，那时埃迪就会穿上这条短裙。这是一条他用剪掉裤腿的牛仔裤做成的短裙。
Once my mom came to visit me at The Palace. And I don't know what mom expected, but what she got was Eddie, naked and relaxed. Eddie reading the New York Times book review section. It made me very nervous when Eddie sat down with my mother, but my mom loved the New York Times book reviews and Eddie must have sensed that because he offered it to her. And the two of them were soon chatting about books they would never have time to read. And quickly, they seemed comfortable together. And that was amazing to me, my mother fully clothed and Eddie not clothed at all.
有一次我妈来看我在“宫殿”的工作。我不知道我妈期待什么，但她看到的是埃迪，赤身裸体、悠闲自在。埃迪正在阅读《纽约时报》书评版。当埃迪坐下来和我母亲在一起时，我感到非常紧张，但我妈喜欢《纽约时报》的书评，埃迪肯定感觉到了，于是他主动把它让给了她。他们很快就谈论起那些他们永远没时间读的书。很快，他们在一起似乎很自在。这对我来说太神奇了，我母亲衣冠楚楚，而埃迪却一丝不挂。
It was only when Eddie leaned over and asked something so private that my mother never told me what it was. That my mom flushed and stormed away from the table.
直到埃迪倾过身去问了一个如此私密的问题——我母亲从未告诉我那是什么问题——我妈才满脸通红地冲离了桌子。
And that's the thing about Eddie. As much as he could win you over, and I liked him, he would always find a way to push things just too far. As if any boundary or border was a foreign thing and it was to be disposed of and gotten through, no matter how you felt about it.
这就是埃迪的特点。尽管他能赢得你的好感，我也很喜欢他，但他总能找到办法把事情推得太远。就好像任何界限或边界都是外来物，必须被处置和突破，无论你的感受如何。
Eddie moved into our house and invited some of The Palace women to sleep with him. And some of them were happy to do it until the most private details of their intimacy started showing up in his speeches, surrounded by big, blinking exclamation points. Look at this.
埃迪搬进我们的房子，邀请了一些“宫殿”的女性和他睡觉。她们中有些人很乐意这样做，直到她们最私密的亲密细节开始出现在他的演讲中，周围环绕着大大的、闪烁的感叹号。你看这个。
The police came two months into Eddie's talks. Eddie was arrested. And soon now, this nude messiah would stand trial. And he felt that, messianic and alone and full of a vision of the world where the pants come down in simultaneous synchronization and whole nations freed from the shackles of clothing, walk freely and hang out in peace.
埃迪演讲两个月后，警察来了。埃迪被捕了。现在，这位裸体弥赛亚即将接受审判。他感觉自己像是一个救世主，孑然一身，满怀着对世界的憧憬：在那里，裤子同时落下，整个国家从衣物的枷锁中解放出来，自由行走，在和平中闲逛。
And Eddie spent the weeks prior to his trial alternating phone calls to Brezhnev and the Kremlin and Jimmy Carter's White House. Eddie made his calls from the corner laundry mat, urging long distance operators to support his new strategy. International nudity day July 4. Disarm now. The pants come off in simultaneous synchronization for world peace. That's the hook. If you're naked, how can you take yourself seriously holding a tank or fondling a nuclear war head? You'd have to set them down.
埃迪在审判前的几周里，交替着给勃列日涅夫、克里姆林宫和吉米·卡特的白宫打电话。埃迪在街角的洗衣店里打电话，敦促长途接线员支持他的新战略。国际裸体日，7月4日。现在就解除武装。裤子同步落下，以实现世界和平。这就是关键所在。如果你赤身裸体，你怎么能在拿着坦克或抚摸核弹头时还认真对待自己？你不得不放下它们。
Someone at the Kremlin actually answered one of Eddie's calls and Eddie just poured it on over the phone, his whole platform. But at the White House, they just put him on hold and left him there. Eddie hardly noticed. His campaign was heating up.
克里姆林宫居然有人接听了埃迪的一个电话，埃迪就在电话里滔滔不绝地讲述他的整个纲领。但在白宫，他们只是让他保持在线，然后就把他晾在那里了。埃迪几乎没注意到。他的竞选正在升温。
Eddie's trial for indecency and his presidential campaign, which takes him to the 1976 Republican National Convention. That's in a minute, when our program continues.
埃迪因猥亵罪受审以及他的总统竞选活动，将他带到了1976年的共和党全国代表大会。一分钟后，节目继续。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme and bring you a wide variety of stories, different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, One Thing. People who are obsessed with one thing.
这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，并为您带来各种各样的故事。今天的节目主题是“一件事”。那些执着于某一件事的人。
We are in the middle of act two. Beau O'Reilly's story continues. His friend, Eddie, is a one-thinger who believes in a kind of utopian nudity and is coming up on trial for indecent exposure. Again, a parental advisory. There's nudity in this story.
我们正在进行第二幕。博·奥赖利的故事继续。他的朋友埃迪是一位“一件事”主义者，他信奉一种乌托邦式的裸体主义，并且即将因公然猥亵罪接受审判。再次提醒，这个故事里有裸体内容。
There was a large crowd at Eddie's trial for indecent exposure. When the judge walked solemnly in and the clerk called out, all please rise, Eddie slipped out of his kilt and his t-shirt and he did rise. The judge found him in contempt and the cops dragged him handcuffed and kilted from the courtroom. Eddie meaning to go willingly, but the crowd was too good to waste. So Eddie shouted over his shoulder, pulling away from the cops to urge them to join him for international nudity day. And the cops moved Edward Hickock Collins from the county jail to the county hospital.
埃迪因猥亵罪受审时，现场挤满了人。当法官庄严地走进来，书记员喊出“请全体起立”时，埃迪脱掉了短裙和T恤，他站了起来。法官判他蔑视法庭，警察把他戴上手铐，穿着短裙拖出了法庭。埃迪本来想自愿离开，但人群太棒了，不容浪费。所以埃迪回头大喊，挣脱警察，敦促他们加入他的“国际裸体日”。警察将爱德华·希科克·柯林斯从县监狱转移到了县医院。
Now Eddie was a lamb at the hospital. He was polite and he was cooperative. He'd had shock treatments before and he didn't wish to have them again. He needed his mind. But the doctors gave him Nembutals and Thorazine, large amounts. And his tongue thickened and his bright eyes grew heavily lidded. And he stumbled of his quotations of good old page 201. And after some weeks, all Eddie was really sure of was that the world would be better off naked. And he was the man to strip it bare. He hung onto that.
在医院里，埃迪就像只羔羊。他礼貌而合作。他以前接受过休克治疗，不想再接受了。他需要他的头脑。但医生给了他大量的戊巴比妥和氯丙嗪。他的舌头变得僵硬，明亮的眼睛变得沉重。他结结巴巴地引用着老书第201页的内容。几周后，埃迪唯一确定的是，如果世界赤身裸体，会变得更好。而他就是那个把世界剥光的人。他坚持着这一点。
Eddie got out on a deep, blue day and he wept because it was June and he was free with International Nudity Day just around the corner.
埃迪在一个湛蓝的日子里出院了，他哭了，因为是六月，他是自由的，而“国际裸体日”即将来临。
Over the month, Eddie's plan spread and took wing. International Nudity Day, that's only a beginning. It's a great beginning. It's a campaign launcher. The Republican Convention, that's set for Kansas City, mere months away.
过了一个月，埃迪的计划传播开来，并展翅高飞。“国际裸体日”，那只是个开始。这是一个伟大的开始。这是一个竞选活动的发射台。共和党全国代表大会定于几个月后在堪萨斯城举行。
The Republicans need to disarm now. The pants come down in simultaneous synchronization candidate. I'm nude run messiah. That's the perfect choice for Kansas City. I'm running. And I'm running nude.
共和党需要现在就解除武装。裤子同步落下的候选人。我是裸奔弥赛亚。那是堪萨斯城的完美选择。我要参选。而且我要裸奔。
And on the fourth of July, 200 of us gathered in the center of downtown. It was a place marked by the crossing of two lines of railroad tracks. Eddie arrived late, running up in his kilt and t-shirt and shaking hands and passing out campaign literature. Someone pulled a baby from the crowd for Eddie to kiss and the crowd cheered.
7月4日，我们200人聚集在市中心。那是一个由两条铁轨交叉标记的地方。埃迪迟到了，穿着短裙和T恤跑来，握手并分发竞选传单。有人从人群中抱出一个婴儿让埃迪亲吻，人群欢呼起来。
And Eddie spoke, he was poignant in his wonder at the beauty of the human body. And then in simultaneous synchronization, the pants came down. I was there and it was great. We all pulled off our clothes. Really only about 30 of us did it, but we were all standing in the front so it felt like a crowd, a naked crowd. And Eddie was ecstatic. He beamed with joy and leaping about, his own clothes flew in all directions with an extra zip that day. The police moved in with paddy wagons, arresting the naked crowd. But they saved Eddie til last.
埃迪发表了讲话，他对人体之美感到惊叹，那令人感动。然后，在同步之中，裤子落了下来。我在那里，感觉棒极了。我们全都脱掉了衣服。实际上只有大约30个人这样做了，但我们都站在前面，所以感觉就像一群人，一群裸体的人。埃迪欣喜若狂。他笑逐颜开，蹦蹦跳跳，他自己的衣服那天异常轻快地向各个方向飞去。警察开着警车冲了进来，逮捕了裸体人群。但他们把埃迪留到了最后。
And before they could reach him, a long freight train raced up the track, just as the cops were moving towards Eddie. He timed it perfectly. Waving and nodding he jumped over the tracks right in front of the engine, leaving the cop on the other side. And by the time the freight train had passed, Eddie was gone. He was already running and he was running nude.
在他们能抓到他之前，一列长长的货运列车就在警察走向埃迪时冲上了轨道。他掐准了时间。挥手点头，他跳过轨道，恰好在火车头前面，把警察留在了另一边。当货运列车经过时，埃迪已经不见了。他已经在奔跑了，而且是赤身裸体地跑着。
Eddie ran all the way to Kansas City, mostly at night. And Playboy magazine picked up his story and sent a reporter and a photographer to follow him. The pictures were all of Eddie naked eating banana splits with a bunch of old farm boys at a Stuckey's or posed on the seat of a big, hog Harley at a rest stop surrounded by big, hairy biker guys. Naked except for a McDonald's cap giving out free french fries and nudity now buttons under the shadow of the golden arches. Playboy magazine bailed him out each time he was arrested.
埃迪一路跑到了堪萨斯城，大部分是在晚上。《花花公子》杂志接手了他的故事，派出一名记者和一名摄影师跟随他。照片里全是埃迪赤身裸体地在斯塔基餐厅和一群老农家男孩吃香蕉船，或者坐在服务区的巨大哈雷摩托车上，周围是高大的、毛茸茸的摩托车手。他除了戴着麦当劳的帽子，在金拱门阴影下分发免费薯条和“现在就裸体”的徽章外，一丝不挂。《花花公子》杂志在他每次被捕时都为他保释。
But when he got to Kansas City, Eddie got cagey. This was the big time and he covered himself, his nude body, his kilt, and his t-shirt in a black three-piece suit he bought at the Salvation Army. He borrowed the Playboy writer's press ID and Eddie boldly moved behind Republican lines, making it to the front steps of the convention center. That was close enough.
但当他到达堪萨斯城时，埃迪变得精明起来。这是关键时刻，他用在救世军买的一套黑色三件套西装遮住了自己——他的裸体、短裙和T恤。他借用了《花花公子》记者的媒体证，埃迪大胆地潜入共和党防线，到达了会展中心的台阶前。那已经足够近了。
And the next day, Eddie found a fruit crate and he wrote soap all over it in black magic marker. And he returned to the convention steps, standing up high on the soap box above the crowd. His whole being overwhelmed with the moment, the power, of his big idea. Blurting out verbiage and joy, his clothes flying and hysterical in all directions. And there were brief looks of childlike wonder across Republican faces in the crowd, but then they were replaced with this all to adult frown of disgust and censor.
第二天，埃迪找了一个水果箱，用黑色记号笔在上面写满“肥皂”。他回到会展中心的台阶上，高高地站在人群上方的肥皂箱上。他的整个人被那一刻、被他宏大想法的力量所淹没。滔滔不绝、欢呼雀跃，他的衣服在各个方向飞舞。人群中共和党人的脸上闪过一丝孩子般的好奇，但很快就被那种成年人特有的厌恶和谴责所取代。
The Kansas City cops, hard men who had been put on kook alert, knocked him from the soap box and they slammed him into the cement steps. And they dragged him bodily away. Eddie's anxious cry of nudity now drowned out by police radios and the charging march of police boots.
堪萨斯城的警察，那些被派去处理疯子的硬汉，把他从肥皂箱上撞了下来，把他摔在水泥台阶上。他们把他拖走了。埃迪焦急的“现在就裸体”的呼喊声被警用无线电和警察靴子整齐的行进声淹没了。
And Eddie stayed in jail for the rest of the convention. His name would never appear on the Republican list of nominees that year. And like so many presidential candidates-- Jesse Jackson, Gary Hart, Paul Tsongas, Ross Perot-- the early days of his campaign would prove to be the most memorable.
埃迪在大会余下的时间里一直待在监狱里。他的名字那一年永远不会出现在共和党的候选人名单上。而且像许多总统候选人一样——杰西·杰克逊、加里·哈特、保罗·宗加斯、罗斯·佩罗——他竞选初期的日子将证明是最令人难忘的。
Edward Hickock Collins had peaked too soon. He returned home to The Palace, but he was never quite the same. Eddie's confidence dropped after Kansas City. He had other big moments. Like attending his Yale class reunion football game and dropping his pants and dashing along the sidelines when Yale scored against Harvard. But each one of these episodes led to jail and more hospitals. Or a stream of Nembutals and shock treatments left Eddie struggling to keep a hold on his mind.
爱德华·希科克·柯林斯达到顶峰太早了。他回到了“宫殿”，但他再也不一样了。埃迪在堪萨斯城之后，信心大减。他还有过其他辉煌时刻。比如参加耶鲁大学的同学会橄榄球赛，脱掉裤子，在耶鲁对阵哈佛时沿着边线奔跑。但这些事件中的每一件都导致他入狱和更多的医院检查。或者，戊巴比妥和休克疗法的洪流让埃迪苦苦挣扎，试图保持清醒。
It's strange when you think about it. That nudity would exact this kind of retribution from our society. Nudity. But Eddie stuck to his vision of the world, his one big idea. That a naked man is a free man and should be allowed to be free.
当你仔细想想，这很奇怪。裸体竟然会从我们的社会中招致这种报复。裸体。但埃迪坚持他看待世界的愿景，他那一个宏大的想法。即一个赤裸的人是一个自由的人，应该被允许自由。
The last I heard of him, he had moved back home to Baldwin, Long Island. Eddie began liberating the neighborhood cats and dogs of their leashes, their choke chains, and their flea collars. That's the thing about a messianic vision, about one big idea. If you follow it to its logical conclusion, you don't know where you'll end up.
我最后一次听到他的消息时，他已经搬回了长岛鲍德温的老家。埃迪开始解放邻里的猫狗，把它们的牵引绳、颈圈和除蚤圈都摘掉。这就是关于救世主愿景、关于一个宏大想法的问题所在。如果你追随它直至逻辑结论，你根本不知道你会走到哪里。
Eddie ended up reading to his cats and dogs, good old page 201 Cather in The Rye. The dogs and cats listened. They were animals. They had no problem with the F word. Nudity came naturally to them.
埃迪最终每天给他的猫狗读那本《麦田里的守望者》第201页。猫狗们听着。它们是动物。它们对那个词没有意见。裸体对它们来说是很自然的。
Chicago playwright Beau O'Reilly.
芝加哥剧作家博·奥赖利。
Act Three, More Than One Thing.
第三幕，不止一件事。
Well, up until now on our program, we've been hearing about eager, full-hearted one-thingers. In this part of the show we turn to reluctant one-thingers. Our first witness, journalist Philip Weiss.
好吧，到目前为止在我们的节目中，我们听到的都是那些充满渴望、全心投入的“一件事”主义者。在节目的这一部分，我们转向那些“不情愿的”主义者。我们的第一位证人，记者菲利普·韦斯。
Philip Weiss writes for the New York Observer and other publications, and he has spent a lot of time with the Clinton conspiracy theorists. These are the people who see a sinister force, who see one thing behind these events. The death of deputy White House counsel Vince Foster in 1993, the raiding of Foster's office after his death, Travelgate, Web Hubbell and whether he was paid off to keep him from cooperating with prosecutors. Some also include on the list drug and gun running through the Mena airport in Arkansas during Bill Clinton's years as governor, various murders and deaths too numerous to list here.
菲利普·韦斯为《纽约观察家》和其他刊物撰稿，他花了很多时间和克林顿阴谋论者在一起。这些人看到了一种邪恶的力量，他们看到这些事件背后有一件事。1993年白宫副法律顾问文斯·福斯特之死，他死后办公室被搜查，旅游门事件，韦伯·哈贝尔以及他是否被收买以防止其与检察官合作。有些人还将阿肯色州梅纳机场在比尔·克林顿担任州长期间的毒品和枪支走私列入清单，还有不胜枚举的各种谋杀和死亡事件。
Well, as he did his reporting, Philip Weiss became persuaded by some of the one-thingers. He saw their logic, but he did not become a one-thinger himself. He spoke with This American Life senior producer Paul Tough. Philip Weiss says that before he first went out to meet the Clinton one-thingers, his year with him was fairly unambiguous.
好吧，在他进行报道的过程中，菲利普·韦斯被一些“一件事”主义者说服了。他看到了他们的逻辑，但他自己并没有成为一个“一件事”主义者。他与《美国生活》资深制作人保罗·塔夫进行了交谈。菲利普·韦斯说，在他第一次出去见克林顿的“一件事”主义者之前，他对他们的看法是相当明确的。
I thought they were really out to lunch. I thought they were nuts and hung up and obsessed. And had nothing really intelligent to say.
我觉得他们简直是疯了。我觉得他们很疯狂、执着且沉迷。而且没有一句聪明话。
So tell me a bit about when you first entered their world in the early weeks or months that you really started dealing with these people. What are they like? What are they like as a group?
那么，告诉我一点当你刚进入他们的世界，在真正开始与这些人打交道的最初几周或几个月里是什么情况。他们是什么样的？作为一个群体，他们怎么样？
Well, some of these people meet the Hollywood casting version of an unhappy obsessive. Some of them do. They're very unpleasant. They have weird idiosyncrasies. They're insistent. They're shrill. And you just think, this is one unhappy camper and I want to get out of his personal space as quickly as possible. Having said that, I've met a number of people who are involved in the Clinton scandals who are very happy people, who are engaging their talents fully.
嗯，这些人里有些人完全符合好莱坞选角版中那种不快乐的强迫症患者。有些人确实如此。他们非常不讨人喜欢。他们有奇怪的特质。他们坚持己见。他们尖刻。你只会觉得，这是一个不快乐的人，我想尽快远离他的个人空间。话说回来，我也遇到过一些参与了克林顿丑闻的人，他们是非常快乐的人，在充分发挥自己的才华。
For most of the conspiracy theorists, the main event of the Clinton presidency is the death of Vince Foster. The official version of the facts of Foster's death concludes that on July 20, 1993, Vince Foster drove himself to Fort Marcy Park in suburban Virginia, parked his car, walked to a secluded spot, and shot himself. But as Philip Weiss found out, there's another version of the facts, meticulously cataloged in another document, an unofficial one.
对于大多数阴谋论者来说，克林顿总统任期内的主要事件就是文斯·福斯特的死亡。关于福斯特死亡事实的官方说法是，1993年7月20日，文斯·福斯特独自驾车前往弗吉尼亚郊区的马西堡公园，停好车，步行至一个僻静处，然后自杀。但正如菲利普·韦斯发现的那样，还有另一个版本的真相，被细致地归档在另一份文件中，一份非官方的文件。
The most important event for me was reading the Sprunt report, which is a classic of sort of call it conspiratorial literature. But it's a study by Hugh Sprunt of Texas, Farmers Branch, Texas, outside Dallas, of the record in the Foster case. And it's brilliant. And when I read that, I realized that the questions that these people have raised about the events in Fort Marcy Park are not trivial and not nuts. They are serious, good, investigative questions.
对我来说最重要的事件是阅读《斯普朗特报告》，这堪称阴谋论文献中的经典。但它是德克萨斯州法默斯布兰奇的休·斯普朗特对福斯特案记录的研究。它非常精彩。当我读到它时，我意识到这些人对马西堡公园事件提出的问题并非微不足道，也不是胡说八道。那是严肃的、好的调查性问题。
The most convincing evidence that Philip Weiss found in the Sprunt report had to do with the possibility that Vince Foster died somewhere other than Fort Marcy Park and that his body was moved there by someone.
菲利普·韦斯在《斯普朗特报告》中发现的最具说服力的证据，与文斯·福斯特可能死于马西堡公园以外的地方，且他的尸体被某人转移到那里的可能性有关。
The report points out that there was no dirt on Foster's shoes, despite the fact that he was supposed to have walked through the park. There were no car keys found in his pocket despite the fact that he was supposed to have driven himself there. There was a missing briefcase, a misquoted witness, eyeglasses too far from the body, and contradictory accounts of what kind of gun was found in Foster's hand.
报告指出，福斯特的鞋子上没有泥土，尽管他本应穿过公园。他的口袋里没有发现车钥匙，尽管他本应是自己开车去的。缺失的公文包、引用错误的证人、离尸体太远的眼镜，以及关于在福斯特手中发现何种枪支的矛盾说法。
And at this point, I don't have any conclusions beyond the strong feeling that there were shenanigans in Fort Marcy Park that his body was brought there, I feel. He may have shot himself somewhere else. I think he probably did shoot himself. The evidence is, to my mind, pretty strong. But there seemed to have been shenanigans.
此时此刻，我没有任何结论，除了强烈的感觉——马西堡公园里有猫腻，他的尸体是被带到那里的，我感觉是这样。他可能在其他地方开枪自杀了。我认为他很可能确实是自杀的。证据，在我看来，相当充分。但似乎有猫腻。
I went to Arkansas a few times. And many reporters have gone to Arkansas and come back shocked. I came back shocked. I felt like the top of my head was blown off. I just felt that things were different down there and that they explained who our president is politically in a way that was not apparent to people on the East Coast who saw the Rhodes scholar and the Yale law school graduate.
我去了几次阿肯色州。许多记者去过阿肯色州后回来都感到震惊。我回来时也感到震惊。我觉得头盖骨都被掀开了。我只是觉得那里的事情很不一样，它们以一种东海岸人无法察觉的方式解释了我们的总统在政治上是谁，而东海岸的人们只看到了罗德学者和耶鲁法学院毕业生。
I thought for a little while that that would be-- as a journalist and writer, that would be my story. And I was in it for a little while and now I'm not in it. And I don't fully understand why I'm not in it and I was a few months ago. I guess that I believe-- again, while I buy their story about this administration more than I buy the mainstream story, there's a level of alienation in some of the stuff I've read just cruising the 'net that I just wasn't ready for. I just feared what I might become.
我有一小段时间认为那会是——作为一名记者和作家，那会是我的故事。我在里面待了一小段时间，现在我不在里面了。我不完全明白为什么我不在里面了，明明几个月前我还陷在里面。我想我是相信——虽然我比相信主流说法更相信他们关于这个政府的故事，但我读到的一些东西，在网上闲逛时读到的东西，那种疏离感是我还没准备好的。我只是害怕我会变成什么样。
When one announces in respectable company that one no longer accepts the official version of events with respect to Vince Foster's death, people look at you funny.
当你宣布在体面的公司里，自己不再接受关于文斯·福斯特死亡事件的官方说法时，人们会用奇怪的眼神看你。
I remember one conversation with an editor and finally this editor just said, look, Vince Foster committed suicide in Fort Marcy Park, OK? And you know, what can you say?
我还记得和一位编辑的一次谈话，最后这位编辑只是说：“听着，文斯·福斯特在马西堡公园自杀了，好吗？”你知道，你能说什么呢？
When your wife is saying to you you're a nut or you've lost perspective. You know, maybe I'm making the wrong call, but that scares me. That threw me.
当你的妻子对你说你是个疯子，或者你失去了视角时。你知道，也许我做出了错误的判断，但这吓到我了。这让我感到困惑。
It's just a question of how much you want to invest yourself in this position, I think. And you pay a price. Your skin is flayed. And that's the traditional price of a heretic. I'm not trying to be self-dramatizing. It's the ancient bargain that society makes with these people. And I don't know if I want to make that investment.
我觉得这只是一个你想在这个立场上投入多少的问题。而且你要付出代价。你的皮肤被剥掉了。这就是异端的传统代价。我不是试图戏剧化。这是社会与这些人之间古老的契约。我不知道我是否想做出那种投资。
One of my first meetings with a person in this community, a guy I've actually become a little friendly with and whom I have a great deal of respect for. And I'm going to call him Patrick because he uses an alias. This is a guy with a very Jimmy Stewart manner and a very casual manner, and he walked me through Fort Marcy Park with great patience, telling me his understanding of what happened on July 20, 1993 when Vince Foster's body was found. And Patrick's story is a very logical one. He had hundreds and thousands of facts at his fingertips that I was and am in no position really to challenge. He's done more research on this than I have.
我与这个社区中的一个人进行的第一次会面之一，一个我实际上变得有点友好，并且对他有很大尊重的人。我要叫他帕特里克，因为他用了化名。这是一个非常有吉米·斯图尔特风度、态度非常随和的家伙，他耐心地带我走过了马西堡公园，告诉了我他对于1993年7月20日文斯·福斯特尸体被发现时发生的事情的理解。帕特里克的叙述非常合逻辑。他手头有成千上万的事实，我当时和现在都无法真正质疑。他对此所做的研究比我多。
And at the end of our trip through Fort Marcy Park I said to him, you know, you've given me a very logical story, Patrick. I'm willing to believe what you're saying. You know, it's very logical. But I might just walk on. What do you think of that?
在我们走完马西堡公园结束时，我对他说：“你知道吗，你给我讲了一个非常合逻辑的故事，帕特里克。我愿意相信你所说的。你知道，这很合逻辑。但我可能会继续前行。你怎么看？”
And what did he say?
他说了什么？
Well he just would say, and accept that-- in this Jimmy Stewart way. Gosh, Phil, and just accept that your government is telling you these lies about the most important death in high office since the Kennedy-- that kind of thing. I said, yeah. Yeah. Given my understanding of how the world works, I'm willing to accept that they have lied to me about this and that I got other things to do now. And I think he just kind of shook his head at that because that understanding is too central to his worldview to go move onto something else.
嗯，他只会用那种吉米·斯图尔特的口吻说：“天哪，菲尔，接受这一点吧——你的政府在关于自肯尼迪以来高层最重要的死亡事件上对你撒了谎——就是那种事。”我说：“是的。是的。鉴于我对世界运作方式的理解，我愿意接受他们在这件事上对我撒谎了，现在我还有别的事要做。”我想他只是摇了摇头，因为那种理解对于他的世界观来说太核心了，以至于无法去关注别的事情。
Philip Weiss is a novelist and columnist for the New York Observer . He spoke with This American Life producer Paul Tough.
菲利普·韦斯是《纽约观察家》的小说家和专栏作家。他接受了《美国生活》制片人保罗·塔夫的采访。
Act Five, Quitting Quitting. Back in 1994, Evan Harris quit everything in her life. Job her, boyfriend, her city. And she started to think about quitting as an abstract idea in and of itself. She started to develop a theory about quitting. She wanted to name the parts of quitting. And she started to publish a zine about quiting with a friend of hers. She's also published a book about quitting called, The Quit.
第四幕，戒掉戒除。1994年，埃文·哈里斯戒掉了她生活中的一切。她的工作，她的男朋友，她所在的城市。她开始把“戒除”本身作为一个抽象理念来思考。她开始发展出一套关于戒除的理论。她想给戒除的各个部分命名。她开始和朋友一起出版一本关于戒除的杂志。她还出版了一本关于戒除的书，名为《戒》。
The more Evan Harris looked around, the more it seemed like everything in the world was made up of quits and quitting. History seemed like a series of violent, elaborate quits by nations and peoples. People's personal lives seemed driven by a series of endings. Quitting became the lens, the one thing through which Evan Harris saw the world.
埃文·哈里斯看得越多，就越觉得世界上的一切都是由戒除和戒掉组成的。历史看起来像是国家和民族一系列剧烈的、精细的戒除。个人的生活似乎是由一系列结束所驱动的。戒除成为了棱镜，成为埃文·哈里斯看待世界的那“一件事”。
The point of quitting is to move in the world and to get bigger and bigger as a person. See, God damn. Sometimes I just start to sound like a nut basically about this. Just what am I talking about? You know, what am I talking about? You have to understand, this is so on my mind. You know, I mean I think about this all the time. I think about this all the time. I'm thinking about getting up and walking out of this room right now. You know, I really am.
戒除的重点在于世界中移动，并作为一个人的规模变得越来越大。看，该死。有时我只是听起来像个关于此事的疯子。我到底在说什么？你知道，我到底在说什么？你必须明白，这太让我挂心了。你知道，我的意思是，我一直都在想这个。我一直都在想这个。我正想着从这把椅子上站起来走出这个房间。你知道，我真的在想。
That tape if from when I interviewed Evan Harris back in 1994. This is back when she made her big sets of quits. She was at the height of her quitting frenzy and her thinking about quitting. At the time she was trying to catalog still all the parts of quitting, the euphoria of the quit, the euphoria that you feel when you get a quit.
那段磁带是我在1994年采访埃文·哈里斯时的内容。那是她做出那一系列大戒除的时候。她正处于戒除狂热和对戒除思考的顶峰。当时她还在试图给戒除的所有部分分类，戒除的快感，当你得到一次戒除时你感受到的快感。
Well now, Evan Harris has quit quitting. Three years after that. Or it quit her. She no longer is in the throes of one thing. I talked to her about it last week.
好吧，现在，埃文·哈里斯已经戒掉了戒除。在那之后三年。或者说是它戒掉了她。她不再处于“一件事”的阵痛中。我上周和她聊了聊。
It was really horrible. It was very, very horrible. And it actually happened in a very, very dramatic way. I was taking this cross country trip and I stopped traveling with the person with whom I was traveling, which was a very big deal. And I was sitting on a bus, a Greyhound bus, traveling from Santa Fe, New Mexico, and I could no longer think about the trip in terms of quitting because a quit of sorts had occurred and the person with whom I was splitting was too important to funnel into the quitting stream.
那真的很可怕。非常，非常可怕。而且它实际上以一种非常，非常戏剧性的方式发生了。我当时正进行长途旅行，我停止了与和我一起旅行的那个人同行，这是一个非常大的事情。我当时正坐在一辆巴士上，一辆灰狗巴士，从新墨西哥州的圣达菲出发，我再也无法用“戒除”来思考这次旅行了，因为某种戒除已经发生了，而与我分手的那个人太重要了，无法被挤进“戒除流”中。
Because the quitting streaming includes the idea of that when you quit you will feel good? That's almost like one of your definitions of quitting from back then.
因为“戒除流”包括了当你戒除时你会感觉良好的想法？那几乎像是你当时的戒除定义之一。
There's that on one level, but then there's an even more serious level, which was that it was not possible to think of this as anything but what it was. That this was a relationship with a person who I love.
那一层有一点，但还有一个更严肃的层面，那就是不可能把这看作除了它本身以外的任何事情。这是一段与我所爱之人的关系。
Right. And it wasn't just this theoretical quit.
对。而不仅仅是这个理论上的戒除。
Right. There was nothing theoretical about it. I was on a Greyhound bus.
对。没什么理论上的东西。我当时正坐在灰狗巴士上。
And so then the fever broke?
所以在那之后高烧就退了？
Then the fever broke.
那时高烧退了。
When quitting was all you thought about, back when quitting was all you thought about, what was that like now that you look back on it?
当戒除是你全部的想法时，回到你全部都想的是戒除的时候，现在回想起来那是什么感觉？
Oh, it was great. It was great. My mind was jumping all the time. And everything was fitting in. It was like a puzzle. It was like figuring out a puzzle. A big, jigsaw puzzle. And I would fit a piece in and then things would start to fit around it.
哦，那太棒了。那太棒了。我的大脑一直在跳动。而且一切都吻合了。就像破解一个谜题。就像破解一个谜题。一个巨大的拼图。我会把一块拼图放进去，然后事情就开始围绕它吻合起来。
When I hear this, I just picture you just sitting down and just pouring these pages out, page after page, like in a dream. Like in a seizure.
当我听到这个时，我脑海中浮现出你只是坐下来，一页又一页地写下这些，就像在梦里一样。就像在发作一样。
Yes, it was automatic writing, Ira. It was automatic writing. It was like someone turned on a faucet.
是的，那是自动书写，艾拉。那是自动书写。就像有人打开了水龙头。
See, but what in your life today can compete with that?
你看，但你今天生活中有什么能与那个竞争吗？
Nothing. Oh, what? Say again.
没有。哦，什么？再说一遍。
No, no, you were saying nothing.
不，不，你在说没有。
I know, but I wanted to think about it more before I said that.
我知道，但我说那句话之前我想再多思考一下。
Well, you know, like do you miss having that faucet going full force all the time?
好吧，你知道，就像你怀念那个一直全力运转的水龙头吗？
Yeah, I do. I really do. Because there was electricity that was very exciting and I think I was much more interesting then. I mean, I think I'm a little bit of a bore sometimes now.
是的，我怀念。我真的很怀念。因为有那种非常令人兴奋的电流，而且我觉得那时我有趣多了。我的意思是，我觉得我现在有时候有点无聊。
And now you don't organize your thinking about the world that way. Now everything doesn't come down to one thing. Everything is kind of everything?
而现在你不那样组织你看待世界的方式了。现在不是所有事都归结为一件事了。一切都只是……一切？
Yes, everything is everything.
是的，一切都是一切。
Do you think that you lost something by now seeing everything in the world as everything and not just boiling everything down to one thing?
你觉得你因为现在把世界看作一切，而不是把一切简化为一件事，而失去了什么吗？
Yes.
是的。
What?
什么？
I am no longer unified. I was unified and now I'm not unified anymore.
我不再统一了。我曾经是统一的，现在不再统一了。
Unified, you mean everything added up to one idea?
统一，你的意思是所有东西都加起来等于一个理念？
Right. I was able to navigate inside of me in terms of that one thing. So I was a unified person. And I actually had an identity.
对。我能够在那一件事的条件下导航我的内心。所以我曾经是一个统一的人。而且我实际上有一个身份。
Can I ask you what else what else have you lost by giving up that phase of your life when you really believed?
我可以问你，通过放弃你真正相信的那段人生阶段，你还失去了什么吗？
Looking at it that way makes it seem like I sacrificed something by moving away from it. But I didn't pick to move away from it. I mean, it abandoned me, Ira. It abandoned me. Really, it did.
这样看，它看起来好像是我通过离开它而牺牲了什么。但我不是选择离开它的。我的意思是，它抛弃了我，艾拉。它抛弃了我。真的，它确实。
You mean it stopped seeming so interesting?
你是说它不再看起来那么有趣了？
No, it stopped being available to me. It's not that I decided to stop thinking about it, it's that it decided to stop visiting me. It stopped calling me. It was terrible. It was horrible.
不，它不再对我可用了。并不是我决定停止思考它，而是它决定停止造访我。它停止给我打电话了。那太可怕了。太可怕了。
There was a time actually, where I was very angry with the one thing. Because it had abandoned me and it was not available to me. It was like the quit and I had been friends, and then something happened and I didn't know what and I had done something terrible and the quit didn't come to my birthday party for no reason. And yeah, wouldn't call me and wouldn't write to me. And just disappeared, vanished, evaporated, abandoned me.
实际上有一段时间，我非常生那件事的气。因为它抛弃了我，而且不再对我可用了。就像“戒除”和我曾经是朋友，然后发生了什么，我做了什么可怕的事情，而“戒除”没有理由地没来参加我的生日派对。而且是的，不会给我打电话，也不会给我写信。只是消失了，蒸发了，抛弃了我。
And so you used to see quitting as being the engine behind everything around us. Do you feel like that is the best explanatory framework with which to understand your life?
所以你曾经把戒除看作我们周围一切事物的推动力。你觉得那是理解你生活的最佳解释框架吗？
Yes and no. Yes and no. The sad thing is that I don't really have a scheme. I attempted to embrace another framework.
是，也不是。是，也不是。可悲的是，我真的没有一个方案。我试图拥抱另一个框架。
You did?
你尝试了？
Yes.
是的。
What was that?
那是什么？
Picking.
挑选。
Picking?
挑选？
Picking.
挑选。
Meaning what?
意思是什么？
Picking anything. See, I'm a big picker. I'm a picker. And also, I like picking. For example, I once had a job as a strawberry picker, which I enjoyed very much. But then, that kind of picking. But also, the kind of picking, picking and choosing.
挑选任何东西。看，我是一个大的挑选者。我是一个挑选者。而且，我喜欢挑选。例如，我曾经有一份工作是草莓挑选员，我非常享受。但那是那种挑选。还有，那种挑选，精挑细选。
Well, I mean as you say that, I mean it occurs to me that this whole scheme is just the mirror opposite of quitting, really. I mean, it's just somebody picking stuff instead of somebody quitting stuff, right?
好吧，我的意思是当你这么说时，我想到的是，整个方案只是戒除的镜面反向，真的。我的意思是，它只是某人挑选东西而不是某人戒掉东西，对吧？
Right, I guess so.
对，我想是这样。
Evan Harris.
埃文·哈里斯。
Our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and myself with Paul Tough, Alix Spiegel, Julie Snyder, and special guest producer Kitty Eisley. Contributing editors Sarah Vowell, Jack Hitt and Margy Rockland.
我们的节目今天由南希·厄普代克和我制作，保罗·塔夫、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、朱莉·斯奈德和特邀制作人凯蒂·艾斯利参与。特约编辑莎拉·沃威尔、杰克·希特和玛吉·洛克兰。
If you want to buy a tape of this program call us at WBEZ in Chicago 312-832-3380. 312-832-3380.
如果您想购买本节目的录音带，请致电芝加哥WBEZ电台，电话312-832-3380。312-832-3380。
Our email address [email protected] .
我们的电子邮箱地址是[email protected]。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金来源鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who describes This American Life staff this way--
WBEZ的管理由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他这样描述《美国生活》的工作人员——
Very unpleasant. They have weird idiosyncrasies. They're insistent.
“非常不讨人喜欢。他们有奇怪的特质。他们坚持己见。”
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
They're shrill and you just think, this is one unhappy camper.
“他们尖刻，你只会觉得，这是个不快乐的人。”